choy cata [ __ ] Bali from Ivory Coast
is working hard to make his dream come
true he wants to become a professional
soccer player to pursue this ambition he
gave up everything his home and his
family if you're a young African boy and
you become a soccer player it gives you
a whole village hope you become a role
model for thousands of people they see
that you sent yourself a goal and didn't
give up but that can feel like intense
pressure the young athlete suffered the
same fate as many others who are
recruited by clubs for a probationary
period but then dropped just weeks later
I pinned all my hopes on it I thought it
was my big chance I gave it my all the
co-trainer said I was good but nothing
came of it it was a blow a blow that
left him facing a difficulty lemma he
didn't want to go home the
disappointment was too great and not
only for his parents there were no other
prospects for him in France he ended up
falling into the hands of shady agents
who secured him a contract with a
provincial club his payment was food and
poured the club promised they would sort
out his immigration papers waited and
waited but the club did nothing my
friend is still there he knows he'll
never get his papers but what can he do
Jubilee is just one of hundreds of young
soccer players from West Africa who have
gone to Paris without papers and are
waiting for their big break
some of them trained as son Denis a club
founded by Campos bilac a former
professional from Cameroon he invests a
lot of energy improving their game you
have to remember that the competition is
tough this young man was recruited by a
Belgian club which dumped him after his
probationary period he continued to
train but then he injured his ankle
without papers or health insurance he
can't go to a doctor he wants to remain
anonymous because he doesn't want his
family to see him this way the club
never even talked to me personally they
had my agent told me they didn't want me
the agent told me I should go home and
that they'd have me back before another
go but I didn't believe them many of
these West Africans aren't even 18 years
old they're out of their depth in the
cutthroat professional soccer industry
Campos Barack lobbies the clubs to take
more responsibility it's not okay what
the club's do what's supposed to become
of these young men if it weren't for my
project they'll have nowhere to go they
don't know anyone here
French and Belgian clubs are constantly
on the lookout for promising young
players from the former colonies who
could make them a lot of money every now
and then they find one a brilliant new
soccer player is a potential goldmine
some Ola toll from Cameroon is now a
star of international soccer
he too was once among the legions of
African soccer players illegally living
in France
Patrick Abraham has helped secure young
players lucrative contracts Stephens
Anzhi came to us when he was 15 when he
was 20 we sold him to Blackburn for a
million euros then he was sold to Stoke
City for 8 million that then - Suvir for
8 million and we always get a percentage
we get a car every time he switches
clubs the club's recruitment practices
are now so controversial that most of
them refused to talk to us in front of
the cameras until a few years ago
Amiens SC was among the clubs that
recruit young men from West Africa these
kids feel when they're told they're not
going to be taken on how disappointed
they are it can do a lot of damage these
days Allianz agents stick to looking for
the next generation in city suburbs
coulibaly is still hoping to strike
lucky he's now a father and lives with
his girlfriend's mother on the outskirts
of Paris he didn't end up on the street
like so many West Africans who moved to
France when I come home in the evenings
my family's waiting for me they ask me
how I am how my day was that warmth that
support you need it simple affirmative
she busts it Oh
Cavalli is now training to be a sports
counselor he still hopes to become a
professional soccer player one day but
in the meantime he's found a way to earn
a living